kampf gegen das corona virus immer mehr
menschen in deutschland sind infiziert
talfahrt an den börsen die wirtschaft
weltweit spürt enorme folgen eskalation
in syrien nach dem angriff auf türkische
soldaten fordert die türkei hilfe von
der nato und will die grenzen zur eu für
flüchtlinge öffnen und entschädigung für
vw kunden der autobauer zahlt anklagende
dieselfahrer bis zu 6000 257 euro
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber und amt in allen und
herzlich willkommen ein weiterer sehr
ereignisreicher nachrichten tag heute um
7 sport habe auch in der sendung nachher
mit kristin otto in 15 minuten nahmen
die welt im kampf gegen das corona virus
es sind zum teil drastische maßnahmen es
sind erhebliche folgen für die
wirtschaft und vor allem immer mehr
fälle wobei wir uns gewöhnen müssen an
die tatsache dass die tatsächliche zahl
der menschen die das virus in sich
tragen nicht bekannt ist und deshalb
auch viele andere prognosen schwierig
sind offiziell bestätigt und erkannt
sieht es in deutschland im moment so aus
es gibt bei uns im moment 68 menschen
die sich bislang mit dem virus infiziert
haben bzw hatten die meisten davon
aktuell in nordrhein-westfalen im kreis
heinsberg
in rheinland pfalz ist es einer in baden
württemberg sind zu den bisherigen
offiziellen fällen heute noch fünf
hinzugekommen
auch in bayern hessen und schleswig
holstein gibt es nun je einen
infizierten tobias häfner über die
situation
diagnose corona der erreger ist auch in
norddeutschland angekommen betroffen ein
arzt einer kinderklinik er spürte nach
einem italien aufenthalt symptome und
ließ sich gleich untersuchen sein umfeld
wird nun intensiv geprüft
in nordrhein westfalen müssen 1500
mitarbeiter einer unternehmensberatung
daheim bleiben vorsichtsmaßnahme weil
ein kollege positiv auf das corona virus
getestet wurde
insgesamt so sieht es das robert koch
institut ist das risiko in deutschland
nur gering bis mäßig und selbst für
infizierte gilt keine panik die meisten
spüren eine normale erkältung nur bei
knapp 20 prozent wird es nach einer
woche schlimmer wenn man so einen
schweren krankheitsverlauf hat dann kann
es sein dass man bis zur genesung 34
oder im extremfall auch sechs wochen
dass es auch china beschrieben braucht
experten tipps für den alltag nicht
vorschnell zum schutzmasken greifen und
vor allem finger weg von
desinfektionsmitteln im dauereinsatz
händewaschen reicht und verhindert
allergien und andere hautprobleme
übrigens auf internet marktplätzen
nutzen geschäftemacher längst die angst
der menschen wucherpreise stadt faire
angebote wirkliche probleme könnte es
eher für medizinisches personal geben
etwa einen mangel an schutzanzügen wir
tun gerade alles so auch morgen im
krisenstab und noch mal zu schauen was
wir in deutschland an lagerbeständen
haben und vor allem auch rechtlich
sicher zu stellen
notfalls auch durch beschlagnahmung oder
export verboten dass jetzt auch nichts
mehr das land verlässt
auch über ein anderes problem spricht
der krisenstab zur stunde
großveranstaltungen verbieten oder nicht
die schweiz hat schon gehandelt der
genfer autosalon abgesagt rückbau statt
hightech schau in den messehallen mehr
als 1000 personen gleichzeitig dürfen
sich in der schweiz bis mindestens mitte
märz nicht mehr versammeln
die auswirkungen sind komplett nicht
annähernd zu überschauen talfahrt an den
börsen auch heute wieder und viele
unternehmen die sich in krisensitzungen
darauf einstellen müssen was das virus
mit ihrem geschäft macht in arbeit ist
bis zu 20.000 container an bord so kommt
ein schiff normalerweise aus china doch
jetzt kommt kaum noch 1 darunter leiden
die spediteure sowie andreas janetzko er
leitet ein weltweites
logistikunternehmen zuerst musste er
seine filialen in china schließen
nun hat
sein personal in den deutschen häfen
kaum noch zu tun
china ist einer unserer stärksten märkte
und wir spüren jetzt die tatsächlich die
auswirkungen weil die schiffe brauchen
ungefähr 30 tage um hierhin zu kommen
und wir sehen in den ersten büros in
deutschland wir haben elf
niederlassungen in deutschland dass wir
dort doch einen massiven rückgang an
arbeit haben und werden sicherlich in
den nächsten wochen auch über kurzarbeit
nachdenken müssen china ist der größte
handelspartner deutschlands das
handelsvolumen rund 200 milliarden euro
pro jahr
am meisten leiden die die komplett von
den chinesen abhängig sind maik
stockmann importiert sportartikel aus
china und verkauft sie an große ketten
wie zum beispiel aldi die werbeprospekte
für inline skates sind schon gedruckt
doch nun kann er nicht liefern
jetzt drohen vielleicht vertragsstrafen
und umsatzeinbußen bestimmt je nachdem
ob für sie ein offenes haus wieder
reinbekommen und die 15 bis 20 prozent
unserer jahres umsetzen
und selbst wenn einzelne fabriken jetzt
wieder anlaufen ein schiff aus china
braucht ungefähr 30 tage eine ganz
schwierige woche an den börsen war das
ist dass man muss schon bis zur
finanzkrise 2008 zurückgehen um
ähnliches zu sehen
da werden valerie haller nicht nur
aktienwerte von nicht mit da geht es um
mehr
ja da geht das ja auch um die private
altersvorsorge vieler menschen die
zumindest anteilig mit ihren pensionen
und renten fonds in aktien investiert
sind und außerdem hat das natürlich auch
eine große signalwirkung der dax macht
die krise sichtbar erst ein seismograph
dafür wie es der wirtschaft geht und der
kurssturz kann deswegen eine
kettenreaktion in gang setzen
unternehmen investieren weniger
verbraucher halten sich mit größeren
anschaffungen zurück das wiederum drückt
auf die kurse und führt zu neuen
verkäufen an der börse der dax zum
handelsschluss mehr als deutliche -
knapp vier prozent seit montag hat er
gut 13 prozent eingebüßt das ist der
größte wochenverlust seit über acht
jahren viel hängt davon ab wie lange die
epidemie sich jetzt hinzieht je länger
umso größer der schaden bei unternehmen
und dem dax
fakt ist solche kursverluste gab es
tatsächlich zuletzt zur finanzkrise 2008
an der börse fürchtet man dass
deutschland in eine rezession stürzen
könnte von einer delle im ersten quartal
geht man inzwischen fest aus
in frankfurt vielen dank und auch im
internet finden sie bei uns wichtige
ständig aktualisierte informationen zum
corona virus in einem live blog auf
heute de und in der heute app der
arbeitsmarkt in deutschland ist weiter
stabil vor allem wegen der milden
witterung noch hat das virus keinen
einfluss dort die bundesanstalt für
arbeit registrierte im februar zwei
millionen 396.000 arbeitslose das sind
30.000 weniger als im januar die quote
unverändert bei 5,3 prozent im vergleich
zum februar des vergangenen jahres sind
es 23.000 arbeitslose mehr
unser nächstes wichtiges thema heute
eskalation in syrien krieg und das mit
potenziell erheblichen folgen auch für
europa bei einem luftangriff durch
syrische regierungstruppen starben mehr
als 30 türkische soldaten die türkei
antwortete mit vergeltungsangriffen
seit dezember toben die kämpfe in der
gegend um tripp bereits der letzten
hochburg der rebellen im land machthaber
baschar al assad will sie mit russischer
hilfe vertreiben die rebellen werden
unterstützt von der türkischen armee in
dem chaos strandeten fast eine million
menschen an der grenze zur türkei und
die droht jetzt sie werde den weg für
die flüchtlinge nach europa frei machen
wenn der westen ihr nicht hilft und
zeigt heute dass die ersten bereits
unterwegs sind dominik löschmeister zu
hunderten machen sich die flüchtlinge
auf den weg richtung griechische und
bulgarische grenze bisher waren sie in
der türkei untergekommen nach dem
syrischen angriff auf türkische soldaten
machen gerüchte die runde
ankara kontrolliere die grenze nicht
mehr die türkei hat interesse an diesen
bildern
sie machen druck auf europa wo viele
hinwollen
mein ziel ist deutschland ich will dahin
es gibt syrer in unserer gruppe
palästinenser und von anderen ländern
der weg ist frei wir dürfen über die
grenze alle haben uns gesagt es geht
jetzt die grenzen sind offen ihr könnt
gehen wann ihr wollt gestern waren bei
einem luftangriff auf türkische truppen
in der syrischen provinz idlib 33
türkische soldaten getötet worden
die türkei reagierte mit
vergeltungsangriffen auf syrische
stellungen der eskalation belastet auch
die angespannten beziehungen zwischen
der türkei und russland
obwohl die standorte unserer truppen
zuvor mit den zuständigen der russischen
föderation vor ort koordiniert worden
waren fand dieser angriff statt und er
ging weiter ankara veranlasst eine
dringlichkeitssitzung der nato der
generalsekretär bekräftigt die
solidarität mit der türkei die allianz
verurteilt die anhaltenden wahllosen
luftangriffe des syrischen regimes und
russlands in der provinz idlib erste
flüchtlinge sind inzwischen auf der
griechischen insel lesbos angekommen
andere versuchen über die landgrenze
nach griechenland zu gelangen
dort setzt die polizei tränengas ein
spätestens jetzt betrifft die eskalation
in idlib europa ganz konkret ja das ist
eine entwicklung über die wir nochmal
reden müssen mit unseren korrespondenten
in istanbul und in brüssel zunächst jörg
brase was die türkische regierung da
macht ist dass jetzt mehr als eine
drohung an europa also ändert sich da
etwas grundlegendes was die flüchtlinge
angeht also präsident erdogan hat er in
der vergangenheit ja schon öfter damit
gedroht dass er die tür öffnen will für
flüchtlinge richtung europa und diese
tür die hat die türkei heute in der tat
einen spalt weit geöffnet wir haben den
beitrag gesehen einige hundert
flüchtlinge haben sich auf den weg
gemacht und einige haben es auch
geschafft auf die griechische seite ist
scheint tatsächlich so dass die türkei
die unterstützung des westens erzwingen
will
die unterstützung bei der lösung der
krise in edle weise man will dass druck
ausgeübt wird auf moskau aber auch auf
das regime in moskau und man möchte
hilfe dabei das zum einen nicht noch
mehr flüchtlinge in die türkei kommen
und das
die zahl derer die sich bereits im land
aufhalten diese 3,6 millionen dass diese
zahl reduziert wird und um diese ziele
zu erreichen ist die türkei
offensichtlich bereit einen hohen preis
zu zahlen
stefan leifert für uns in brüssel da
gibt es ja jetzt viel was die eu
aufschrecken sollte natürlich das
schicksal der menschen dann aber auch
wie sehr russland damit spielt die
türkische drohung wie sieht denn die
reaktionen in europa aus die eu reagiert
wird sich in den nächsten stunden und
tagen erstmal nicht so sehr in brüssel
entscheiden sondern in griechenland und
bulgarien bei der länder sind im moment
massiv dabei in diesen stunden den
grenzschutz massiv hochzufahren
griechenland auch mit hilfe des militärs
und aus bulgarien wird berichtet dass
die regierung meter hohe zäune in
richtung türkische grenze schafft hier
in brüssel ist die sorge eine doppelte
zum einen dass diese eskalation jetzt in
einen offenen krieg münden könnte und
die zweite sorge ist dass sie dazu führt
dass es wieder zu einem massenhaften
anstieg von flüchtlingen in richtung
europa kommt was die türkische drohung
angeht war man hier von seiten der
eu-kommission den ganzen tag mit der
türkischen regierung in kontakt und hat
offiziell zumindest die zusage dass sich
ankara an alle zusagen aus den
flüchtlings fakt gebunden fühlt aber
hier in brüssel weiß natürlich jeder wie
schnell sich das ändern kann und wie
groß das app rettung
erpressungspotenzial ist militärisch da
sind sich eu und nato einig will man
nicht in diesem konflikt eingreifen
politisch hofft man darauf dass es in
den nächsten tagen zu einem gipfel kommt
bei dem ankara und moskau an einem tisch
mit der eu sitzen um die lage zu
deeskalieren
die einschätzung unserer korrespondenten
in istanbul und in brüssel vielen dank
und damit zurück nach deutschland und zu
einer wichtigen nachricht für 260.000 vw
kunden
die werden schon bald ein brief bekommen
mit einem angebot des konzerns vw zahlt
ihnen eine entschädigung wenn sie auf
weitere ansprüche verzichten
das gilt für alle die bis ende 2015
einen manipulierten diesel gekauft und
die sich später der musterklage
angeschlossen hatten
darauf hat sich vw jetzt nach einigem
hin und her mit verbraucherschützern
geeinigt oliver deuker berichtet karl
ernst müller steht nach dem vergleich
eine entschädigung zu wie 260
und weiteren diesel besitzern je nach
alter und modell des fahrzeugs bietet
volkswagen zwischen 1.350 bis 6.200 57
euro an
so wie es das einschätzung wie ich das
rechne ich denke ich dass ich damit
nicht zufrieden sein kann weil es
weniger als 50 prozent meines
wertverluste sind beim
volkswagen-konzern ist man dagegen recht
zufrieden 830 millionen euro kostet der
deal eine schmerzhaft hohe summe aber es
ist die beste lösung für volkswagen und
die deutsche justiz und auch unsere
kunden mehr als 400.000 betrogene
volkswagen kunden hatten sich der muster
feststellungsklage angeschlossen doch
diese besitzer die ihr auto nach 2015
kauften oder ihren wohnsitz nicht in
deutschland hatten bekommen kein
vergleichsangebot der
verbraucherzentrale bundesverband hat
für mehr gestritten
vor allem auch dafür dass volkswagen
allen im klage register eingetragen und
verbrauchte ein angebot macht aber im
rahmen der schwierigen verhandlungen ist
das ergebnis das was maximal vereinbar
war
volkswagen will nun bis mitte märz
individuelle entschädigungsangebote
machen begleitet wird die abwicklung von
verbraucherzentrale bundesverband und
unabhängigen wirtschaftsprüfern das
heißt mit diesem vergleich ist
sichergestellt dass die kunden nicht
blind dem unternehmen vertrauen müssen
von dem sie bereits einmal betrogen
wurden ob die betroffenen kunden das
vergleichsangebot annehmen oder lieber
einzeln weiter klagen wollen müssen sie
bis zum zwanzigsten april entscheiden so
wir bleiben noch kurz beim auto und
kommen zu der frage ob ein generelles
tempolimit auf deutschen autobahnen gut
ist für den klimaschutz
da gibt es heute neue zahlen des
umweltbundesamtes und die sagen ganz
klar ja dürfte nur noch höchstens 130
gefahren werden würden etwa fünf prozent
weniger co2 auf den autobahnen
ausgestoßen
bei tempo 120 6,6 prozent weniger
das alles könnte sofort umgesetzt werden
und würde nur wenig kosten sagt die
studie
und sie sagt auch dass gerade im
straßenverkehr bislang zu wenig co2
eingespart wurde
sieben jahre renovierung an baustellen
hatten sich viele besucher der
gemäldegalerie alte meister in dresden
gewöhnen müssen
doch ab heute ist alles neu daneben 7
100 gemälden sind jetzt auch 420
skulpturen zu sehen die bronze statuette
des kriegsgottes mars aus dem
sechzehnten jahrhundert neben der
schlummernden venus die galerie ist
berühmt für meisterwerke italienischer
holländischer und deutscher maler
michael bewerunge nimmt uns mit
sie ist nach wie vor die unbestrittene
königin hier die sixtinische madonna von
raffael ihre sanfte anmut und die
komposition der farben kommen noch
besser zur geltung seit das alte grau
der wandbespannung durch ein kräftiges
rot ersetzt wurde von frischen
hintergrundfarben und einem neuen
lichtkonzept profitieren alle gemälde
wir haben jetzt auch eine ganz neue
hänge das publikum wird sehen dass die
leuchtkraft der werke ganz anders zur
geltung kommt es ist sehr dicht also wir
zelebrieren die fülle die wege haben
hier sind sie alle versammelt die großen
meister aus europas goldenem zeitalter
rubens mal feucht fröhlich mal sinnlich
in seiner leda mit dem schwan
rembrandt feiert lustvoll das leben und
auch vermehrt mit dem bildnis der
kupplerin aus dem vollen
[Musik]
und natürlich bellotto genannt canaletto
der dresden mit dem gleichnamigen blick
berühmt gemacht hat neu ist die
integration von skulpturen in die
ausstellung mal sollen sie den
betrachter scherzhaft inspirieren mal
verdeutlichen dass sie den alten
meistern
tatsächlich oft als vorbild dienten
zum streifzug durch die europäische
kunstgeschichte lädt die galerie alte
meister schon heute abend ab 22 uhr
wieder ein heute und morgen ist der
eintritt frei
ja es gibt auch noch gute nachrichten
zum beispiel auch beim sport oder das
sind genau und ich gucke auch nach
sachsen die nähe von dresden da gab es
einen historischen dreifach-erfolg für
die deutschen skeleton männer bei den
weltmeisterschaften in altenberg in
einem herzschlagfinale entschieden nach
vier läufen winzige fünf
hundertstelsekunden zwischen gold silber
und bronze für die gastgeber spektakulär
und unerwartet drei deutschen skeletoni
auf dem podest alexander kastner bronze
silber für axel jung und der neue
weltmeister christopher groth er ich
glaube ich kann es gar nicht realisieren
durchsagen also ist wahnsinn auch vor
dem publikum hier ist was ganz
besonderes altenberg ist meine bahn
ich hab mir jetzt wieder im bayern
trikot zurückgeholt
[Musik]
zuvor hochspannung droht er mit zwei
zehntelsekunden vorsprung nach lauf 3
und dann auf einmal eine hundertstel
zurück aber im unteren bereich gelingt
dem außenseiter eine nahezu perfekte
fahrt im ziel liegt er wieder mit 2 100
sekunden vor aksel jung welch ein
triumph für christopher grote maximale
strafe für chinas schwimm stars sohn jan
der dreimalige olympiasieger ist vom
internationalen sportgerichtshof cas als
wiederholungstäter zu einer sperre von
acht jahren wegen dopings verurteilt
worden
seine titel werden allerdings nicht
bekannt lausanne internationale
sportgerichtshof cas heute mittag der
generalsekretär veröffentlicht das
urteil gegen sony an
sie hat sich der athlet wird von heute
an die für acht jahre gesperrt
im november noch hat es zum young bei
einer anhörung in montreux seine
unschuld beteuert der chinesische
superstar war 2014 bereits wegen dopings
für drei monate gesperrt wurde 2015
weltmeister 2016 olympiasieger der
vorwurf jung habe 2018 dopingproben
zerstört veranlasste den weltverband
fina nicht ihn zu bestrafen
2009 10 noch wurde young weltmeister
diese bilder wird wohl nicht mehr geben
acht jahre sperre verhängte der kas
young hat bereits einspruch angekündigt
ein düsteres kapitel zu viel
vielen dank dann kommen noch kurz aufs
wetter schauen nach schnee und orkanböen
gestern wird das wochenende im
wesentlichen wieder mild windig
allerdings mit einigem regen details
gleich von katja horneffer ich empfehle
ihnen das heute journal mit dem kollegen
claus kleber um 22 uhr am wochenende ist
petra gerster hier für sie da vom
gesamten team danke fürs interesse und
ihnen einen angenehmen freitagabend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren morgen geht der
meteorologische winter zu ende und er
war viel zu wahren vergleich zum
vieljährigen klimatologischen mittel der
jahre 1961 bis 1990 3,9 grad zu warm und
er war auch zu sonnig und zu nass dabei
allerdings gab es große regionale
unterschiede so fielen in lüchow 21
prozent in der mit 100 89 prozent dessen
was man erwarten könnte
und jetzt kommt in den letzten stunden
noch mal ein bisschen regen zum teil
auch schnee dazu es wird deutlich milder
und morgen erwischt uns schon gleich das
nächste regenband heute nacht also
regnet es im westen und im osten ist
auch schnee oder schneeregen dabei und
da kann es glatt werden
denn ungefähr östlich von hamburg
göttingen würzburg und ulm sinken die
temperaturen in richtung gefrierpunkt
oder knapp darunter
im westen bleibt es milder die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen dann
zwischen 8 grad auf rügen und 16 grad im
breisgau
und nachdem der regen der nacht nach
osten abgezogen ist wird es erst mal
freundlich dann aber kommen neue
regenwolken von westen heran das wird
stürmisch in der eifel auch an der
nordsee und wechselhaft geht's dann in
den nächsten tagen auch weiter ein
schönes wochenende